i mean first of all i cannot keep up
with you another music competition show
what was it about this project that you
were like yes absolutely well i think
most people know me as more of a
vocalist but i'm also a songwriter so it
was really cool i loved um
i actually found out about it like 20
years ago when i first started going
overseas and i thought it was an amazing
concept and how it was um how it came to
fruition was cool but i i love that it's
about the song and songs are so
important i feel like sometimes we lose
sight of that like with with records and
sometimes we just go for something quick
and easy and and this is about a song
[Music]
aside from this lovely lady what drew
you to this project um
the song side of it because like she
said i'm a songwriter too so i got my
career based off of me being a
songwriter for dr dre so i know that
great songs
you know got up on someone's career
it could also you know change the world
too as far as if you write the right
songs you write the right melodies the
right words so this show was appealing
to me for many reasons that it brings
states together that is bringing peace
to the world and it's a competitive show
where it's not about a big name or this
is about the best song you two obviously
worked together on the voice when snoop
you served as a mega mentor but how far
back do you do you two really go
i don't remember the award show it was
but it was a long time ago i wonder if
it was like the mtv award was in the 90s
2000s 2000s
it was early 2000s right after it was
like after i ended up winning idol and i
was performing at a show and he
i he'd we passed each other and he said
my name and i was just like
what did you say his name i was like
kelly clark
snoop dogg
and your reaction was you know my name i
was like freaking out i like thought it
was so cool but he was just so kind and
honest honestly
not everyone was super kind in the
beginning like after that show cause it
was the first season nobody knew you
know in fairness what was gonna happen
but um it was just i remembers vividly
because it was a very kind woman he made
me feel good so yeah what is it like for
you to hear that all those years later
your kindness
i mean it's a good thing because you
know you want to treat people with love
and respect just in case you come across
them again
and it's a beautiful thing that god put
our spirits together to work together so
we can share that moment and then add
some more to it yeah you'll never know
when you'll be back together hosting a
big show for nbc it's so big too we just
saw the stage for the first time it's
enormous what do we have to do to get a
snoop kelly collab
all right no i'm just kidding
right now
i'll be like let's do it
i don't know i am going to do a i know i
was challenged so now i'm like i don't
even know why i haven't done like gina
juice or something like that i haven't i
don't know why but i'm going to do that
on my show so snoop your thoughts about
this we got to make it happen i you're
into it i covered i covered legend john
legend he liked it he said he liked it
we're going to work don't worry okay
we're too close to each other not to get
it in i truly love this energy so much
and what's so great too is it falls at a
time in your life you are about to go
into your 40s
literally smacked up in the middle of
the show you have a lot to celebrate i
do what do you remember about your 40s
remember 10 years ago
when i was in my
when i first walked on the fourth floor
um what i remember was i had i had lost
all of my childish ways then i became
more of a man and i became more of a
businessman understanding where i wanted
to go in life
and i feel like once you get to your 40s
you start to understand what's necessary
and what's
what's not you know what i mean so
you'll make better decisions for
yourself
[Music]
yeah
yeah this will come with the territory
that's what i've come to find out as a
50 year old man that
in my 40s i got real good at what i do
so now i can just coach i love that oh
you'll have a lot of plan yeah that's my
plan you'll have a lot to celebrate here
in april on set with him yes that's my
plan april 24th
yeah you're just wanting it to be 4 20.
that day that [ __ ] that is just in your
brain
i was close to being super cool
like
is that your birthday
4 24. you got to add four days maybe
it's just four days of celebration
we start on the 20th when we get to the
24. well we'll pretend now obviously you
two are such a dynamic duo what makes
you the perfect team for the show i
think because people didn't expect it
but i also think as different as people
might think we are we do both love
supporting artists we love feeling good
we love like you know what i'm saying
like music that really moves you i think
we both can agree on that so and i think
we both our underdogs in our own careers
like in the beginning like you know
nobody expected me to win the thing i
was on and i don't know if people
believed in you right off the bat but i
think that we really work hard to get
where we are and we believe in helping
other artists do the same